[Music]
larry king you got to love larry king is
one of my favorites
he was on tv uh you know for a long time
over 75 years
and uh he has been super busy super busy
he's opening a bagel shop in beverly
hills he's doing a stand-up tour
but i miss watching the guy on
television he was part of the fabric
of american media and i miss the guy
that's why tonight ladies and gentlemen
i am thrilled to announce
that larry's back with another episode
of his brand new
show and once again this is special and
i don't think it's ever been done before
it's going to be broadcast from the
rafters of my studio
so now please welcome live from 30 feet
above me larry king
oh hey conan
hi
i'm back i'm back conan good to see you
larry now uh let's uh let's see we're
all so excited
me too let's see
let's see a little of your new show
larry let's see a little bit okay thanks
conan okay
okay hey
i'm back uh
ah they still love me let's take some
phone calls phil
from round rock texas you're on with
larry king
go hi larry i love the new show
thanks phil we just started what's on
your mind well do you ever worry about
falling well i'll be okay they got my
suspenders nailed to the catwalk all
right that's fine larry
i didn't know that you're going to take
calls from tallahassee florida
you're on hi larry larry whose name
is written on the beam over there right
there
in the black pen humphrey bogart they
shot the big sleep here
back in 1946. you know some projects
shot in this studios
are real classics unlike the one they're
shooting down there right now
hey you know larry just keep those
comments our next call
is rob from st louis rob you're on
larry i love the new show uh do you mind
do you miss being on a real network
that sounds like a good question for
conan
all right now wait a minute that is it
i'm trying to give you a space no more
calls wait a minute
okay i should do it like i did my own
show let's welcome my first
guest the actor the comedian the
all-around nice guy let's hear it
joining me in the rafters
andy richter
andy i don't know how to tell you this
but i have always considered you you the
real star of the show
me too larry me too that's fine that's
great so happy for both of you
look i'm going to proceed with the show
all right star of the new film the
hangover part two comedian
zed galifianakis is here
look how tiny he is he's a small man you
know
physically and spiritually
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who else is on oh oh fell okay thanks
for the uh
thanks for moving me along larry from
the discovery channel series deadliest
catch sig hansen is on the show
the deadliest catch meets the deadliest
host
good one larry just a joke it's just a
joke
andy you're done you're through and
musical guest rafael sadiq
on the show andy i got an idea
ah what is here we go to nate nails
we'll have a corned beef sandwich we'll
go for this fits all right sure i've got
some time
goodbye to both of you let's hear it for
larry king
in the raptors ladies and gentlemen you